hey what's up guys my name is Ayana
welcome back to my batch rendering mini
series the last time we took a look at
dynamic geometry basically how we could
populate our vertex buffer on the fly as
we're rendering so that we could
introduce all of this kind of batch
rendering stuff to not be static but be
dynamic check out that video if you
haven't already and now we're actually
nearing the end of this series finally
because some of us want to get back to
doing other things and today we're gonna
talk about our index buffer and learn
how we can actually make our index
buffer how we can expand it to support
all of the different quads all of the
different geometry that we actually want
to render now last time I gave you guys
a little bit of an exercise I said at
the end of the episode see if you can
figure out how we can actually extend
that index buffer so I hope that many of
you tried my little challenge and have
hopefully worked out the solution for
yourselves because today I'm gonna show
you how to do it and to be honest it's
really not that hard if we look at the
index buffer that we have and I'll
probably jump into the code and explain
it there because it will be a little bit
easier to understand when you actually
see stuff but our index buffer is made
up of a repeating pattern and kind of
goes 0 1 2 2 3 0 that's what makes up a
quad we draw two triangles right next to
each other from the first four vertices
in our vertex buffer and that's what
makes up a square that's what makes up
our quad so if we take that pattern and
we extend it over as many causes we need
which we're going to define a pretty
fine value here then we're going to get
our index buffer being able to support
all of our different quads that we want
to render now in a batch renderer it's
likely you may want to render more than
just quads for example maybe you want to
render lines and that requires a
slightly different index buffer but for
quads the benefit is that a quads index
buffer is easily repeatable and
expandable and scalable and extrapolate
able whatever you guys get the point
across as many causes we want to render
it's not like a 3d model where the
indices may be completely different
model to model and you obviously need a
unique index buffer per model most
likely with quads things are a lot
simpler as you'll see so let's jump in
and see how we can extend our index
buffer if we take a look at the way that
we currently handle our index buffer
it's made up of these indices 0 1 2 2 3
0 and then later 4 5 6 6 7 for this
makes up our second quad this makes up
our first quad
and as I mentioned you can see that
there is a pattern here unlike the
vertex buffer which is obviously
something that you can't predict I'm in
it it entirely depends on the scene that
you're rendering the index buffer really
is kind of the same we just kind of
scale this pattern over all of the
quotes that we want to render so that
means that we can kind of create this up
front now at the moment we're creating
our vertex buffer up front as well we're
not filling it with any kind of data
because of course that's impossible for
us to know until we actually start
rendering over here in the update
function however with indices of course
we do know the patterns so we can
actually say that if we want 1,000
vertices which translates to 250 quads
then we can fill our index buffer with
the correct indices so the first step is
deciding how many quads you want to
actually draw what is the maximum number
of quads that I can draw in a single
draw call so just arbitrarily throwing a
number out there let's just say 1000
with that in mind I'm actually going to
come over here just before we create all
of our vertex arrays and all of that and
just write in some constants so we're
gonna have a constant size T Max quad
count and as mentioned I'm gonna set
that to 1000 and then we're also going
to from this max quad count create a max
vertex count and also a max index count
so in other words we're basically
calculating how many vertices we can
have and how many indices we can have so
I'll copy this and I'll change this to
max vertex count max index count now
even though it is called max index count
it's really just the index count because
of course we're just gonna put all those
indices in there
so how many vertices per quad we have 4
so we can just write max plot count
times 4 and how many indices per quads 6
so we can write max quad count times 6
now we know the size of our vertex
buffer in terms of vertices and also the
size of our index before in terms of
indices so with this Max vertex count
I'm gonna take this and instead of just
using 1000 here we're gonna use that max
vertex count variable so in other words
and I'll rearrange this because I kind
of like writing it this way we're gonna
have max vertex count which is 1000
times 4 so 4,000 vertices times the size
of our vertex that's how large our
vertex buffer is gonna be in bytes
coming down here we're gonna do the same
thing for the index buffer what I wanna
do is write
for loop is going to continue this
pattern on for as many indices as we
need which in this case is 6000 indices
I'll comment all this out I'll leave it
here for reference and then what I'm
going to do is write another one of
these U and 32 T indices with the max
index count and then I'm gonna write a
little for loop since we have a
recurring pattern of six numbers here
I'm just gonna increment this I variable
by 6 and then we're gonna handle the
entire pattern of 6 numbers inside this
four loop so what I've done here is I've
encoded this pattern into these kind of
offsets here and then every time we move
through an iteration of this four loop I
increment the offset by four because
four of course is the difference between
all of these indices and that's it we
now have an index buffer that follows
this pattern all the way up to our max
index count and if we scroll down here
to our index bar for this code doesn't
change at all because we've just simply
redefined the size of indices and we're
still storing the mini indices this is
all great now with that in mind we're
pretty much ready to random we don't
really even need to change anything if I
launch this is it still should work
because we're still drawing twelve
indices according to our draw elements
call and obviously changing everything
to a for loop didn't actually change the
first twelve indices they're still the
same values so here we have the exact
same result as last time but the power
of this obviously is the fact that we
can now draw up to 1,000 quads so let's
go ahead and change this kind of create
quad function we have here so that we
can actually write a little for loop
that renders maybe a grid of quads using
our two textures the way that I wrote
this create what function last time as
just a basic example was just a function
that returns this array of four vertices
what I want to do instead is change this
to take in a target buffer and this
function is simply going to add another
four vertices so add another quad into
that target buffer and then increment
the pointer of course so what I'll do is
change the return type to vertex pointer
because it's going to need to return the
position inside the buffer that is up to
and then I'll simply replace all of
these vertices with the target also get
rid of all these vertex variables here
as well and after every vertex I will
increment the buffer pointer finally the
last thing I'll do is actually return
the target buffer position that we're up
to if I scroll down here to the calling
code what I'm going to
is inside this update function I'm gonna
create an array that's essentially going
to store as many vertices as I need so
we're probably not gonna draw it that
many but I'm just gonna Chuck a thousand
in here just for fun really
and what I'm gonna do is write a for
loop that's going to render a grid of
our textures I'll write a nested for
loop here and then also get a pointer to
the block of memory that we've allocated
inside our vertices array which of
course is just some memory on the stack
well then create our quads inside this
for loop and then I'll just set the
texture ID to alternate based on our
position within the grid I'll also keep
one of our original quads whose position
we could control through I am GUI we can
obviously get rid of all these mam
copies here because all of our data is
inside that vertices array and then
we'll just come over here and upload all
of the vertices and that's pretty much
it the only problem is we are still
drawing twelve indices so we have to
make sure that every time we create a
quad we increment some kind of index
counter variables so I'll just come up
here and I'll write our index count I'll
set it to zero and then every time we
draw a quad
I'll just incremented by six and I'll do
the same after our movable quad I'll
obviously use the index account inside
out raw elements call and I think we're
good to go let's go ahead and see what
we get okay so as you can see we now
have a grid of all of these different
quads with different textures and I can
still of course controlled this so now
theoretically speaking we can render up
to 1,000 quads in a single batch because
our index buffer now supports that all
right so as you can see pretty simple
concept then now we can render up to
1,000 quads so the last piece of the
puzzle we've covered pretty much
everything in this mini series I mean we
could cover like texture slots and more
advanced stuff about that and maybe
we'll address that in the future but now
that we have all of these videos and now
that we have all this information the
last step is to kind of put it all
together into a batch renderer how do we
build a renderer out of this that we can
just kind of throw data at and it will
figure out how to batch it all together
and render it in as least amount of
drawers as possible that's what we're
gonna talk about next time anyway hope
you guys enjoy this video if you did
please hit that like button also leave a
comment below with your thoughts or any
other questions you may have things that
maybe I didn't cover or I skipped over
also huge thank you to all the patrons
that helped support this channel and
make videos like these possible patreon
home for search the channel is the best
way to support this channel so if you
guys like what you're seeing and you
want to see more of this stuff in the
future then please show your support on
patreon I will see you guys next time
good bye
[Music]